[MUSIC PLAYING]
GABI FERRARA: Hi, and
welcome to episode
number 199 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Gabi and I'm here with
my colleague, Jon Foust.
Hello, John.
JON FOUST: Hey, Gabi.
How's it going?
GABI FERRARA: Good.
How are you?
JON FOUST: I'm pretty good.
Just came back from
my brother's wedding.
It was amazing.
My sister-in-law,
she hid the fact
that she was pregnant
to all of her guests.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GABI FERRARA: Ah.
JON FOUST: So it
was pretty awesome.
And then we ended up doing the
gender reveal at the wedding.
And they really wanted
a boy, and that's
exactly what they're getting.
GABI FERRARA:
Congratulations on that.
JON FOUST: It was great.
GABI FERRARA: Yeah.
JON FOUST: How about you?
How have you been?
GABI FERRARA: Uh, puppy sitting.
[PUPPY BARKING]
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, for those that don't
know, my puppy was really sick.
But she's nice now.
She's OK now.
JON FOUST: Yeah, I'm going
to make sure to come visit.
GABI FERRARA: Yeah.
So the subject
today is super cool.
We have a peek on
what Google does
to make data
visualization consistent
across multiple
areas within Google.
We're going to be
talking with Manuel Lima.
He's the lead designer at Google
Cloud for data visualization
team.
JON FOUST: And for
a sneak peek at what
our question of the week is--
GABI FERRARA: What are
the most common products
using cloud gaming?
And he's going to
reply after everything.
JON FOUST: Yeah, yeah.
I got asked this by a fellow
Googler, and I went on a rant
for a while, and
they were kind of
interested to see how
many products are actually
used in cloud gaming.
So, I will give you a
few that I've worked with
and a few that I've
seen most commonly used
in a lot of our gaming products.
GABI FERRARA: Now to our
"Cool Things of the Week"--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We have some two new
trainings with GC.
There are five courses
from introduction
to advanced topics,
and four ones in GKE--
Google Kubernetes
Engine-- with four courses
on networking, persistent
storage, and other concepts
that you use in Kubernetes.
Reminding you that Kubernetes,
by default, is stateless.
So, if you want to
do a stateful thing
you need to see the
course or read the docs
because it's a bit different.
JON FOUST: My cool
thing of the week
is that Stadia is
coming next month.
[LAUGHTER]
Of course, I'm going to
be very excited about it.
I've got to use it
hands-on both at I/O
and they had an internal
event at the Game Summit
where we got to play with it for
a bit, so it's kind of amazing.
I can't wait.
Feel free to check out the show
notes for more information,
but it should release on
November 19th of this year.
And the one thing I'm
really excited for
is I'm looking forward
to playing in 4K,
but I don't need a
4K gaming monitor.
You can use a standard monitor
because the resolution is up
to 4K at 60 frames per second.
GABI FERRARA: Oh, wow.
JON FOUST: So, that's what most
4K monitors that you will see,
like most recent monitors
will output if it's not
a specific 4K gaming monitor.
So I'm real excited about that.
And a lot of the games
that got announced
that I've been
playing as a kid, when
they announced those games,
like, I was jumping out
of my seat.
So, I'm just way too
over-excited for it.
GABI FERRARA: I will send
you the link of my TV model.
It's 4K.
I don't if it works.
You're going to have
to tell me later.
JON FOUST: The great thing is
that most TVs will probably
output at 60 frames,
but there are some older
models that will
do 4K at 30 frames,
so it's just a small change.
When you're an avid
gamer like myself,
you'll notice the big difference
between the response time
and refresh rate of monitors.
GABI FERRARA: OK.
My second cool thing
of the week Apigee
was elected by
Gartner Magic Quadrant
on the fourth time in a row as
a leader for the full-cycle API
management in this
year's report.
So if you look at
the quadrant there,
you need to read
the full report.
You cannot just see the
graphic of the quadrant.
You should look at everything.
But it puts us on
highest ability
to execute for our
APIs enterprise,
and most things have APIs,
including games, John.
[LAUGHTER]
So, yeah.
Give it a look.
It's on the show notes, the
links we're always saying here.
JON FOUST: And I just
thought of something new
that just happened today.
So, there was a
Google Hardware event
that I'm not sure if many
of our listeners have seen.
But we announced a
bunch of new products
such as the Pixel
4, new Pixel Buds,
as well as a couple
of new Nest services.
So, if you're really
interested in those things--
you want to have a connected
home, probably a new phone.
And also they announced
the new Pixelbook,
which is kind of
amazing, which I
would be looking forward to
possibly using in my classroom.
Feel free to check out the
event and the link to the event
will be posted in
the show notes.
GABI FERRARA: So now
we're going to be talking
with Manuel Lima about
data visualization,
and I hope you all enjoy.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We're here today
with Manuel Lima.
So, Manuel, who are
you and what do you do?
MANUEL LIMA: I am a
designer by training.
I'm also a researcher
and a writer,
and I work as a design lead
for Google managing data
visualization team as
part of Google Cloud.
GABI FERRARA: You mentioned that
you work for GCP, specifically.
So why is visualization
important to GCP and Google,
in general?
MANUEL LIMA: Well,
Google in general
because if you look
at Google's mission
to organize the
world's information
and make it universally
accessible and useful,
data visualization plays
a huge role, specifically
in making information
accessible and useful, right?
We tend to say that
data visualization makes
the invisible visible.
In a sense, we are able to
decode meaningful patterns
in data, and that's super
critical for Google's mission
overall.
It can also be a huge
differentiator for GCP
specifically, since we
have a lot of really
complex challenges dealing
with data analytics and data
analysis across GCP.
GABI FERRARA: Do you work
together with the BigQuery team
or stuff like that?
MANUEL LIMA: Yeah, we act as
a horizontal team-- that's
how we frame it, horizontal
team being that we are not
part of one specific product, we
work across multiple products.
So we tend to partner
with multiple teams
within GCP and
even across Google.
JON FOUST: I have a question.
How was your team
actually formed?
Like, if you work with
almost every single team,
I can imagine that there has
to be a specific [INAUDIBLE]
for your team be formed
and to be aligned
with so many different teams.
There has to be
[INAUDIBLE] importance.
MANUEL LIMA: Absolutely.
Many of the original
founders of this team,
we call ourselves
the Four Musketeers,
the, sort of, the
core four-person team
that created this group
in the first place.
We were actually
working on Stackdriver.
We were part of the
original cloud DevOps group.
So Stackdriver was a
Google acquisition,
I would say, maybe
five or six years ago,
and they do a lot
of monitoring--
monitoring different
services, servers--
so you can imagine, there's
a lot of data visualization
elements to it.
Many complex
different dashboards
using line charts, bar charts,
and so on to visualize, again,
services, infrastructures,
and so on.
So we, being part of
that original team,
were already very compelled
to be in that space.
We are all very passionate
about data visualization.
But at some moment
in time, we felt
there was a huge demand
for more complex,
sophisticated visualizations,
and not just by Stackdriver
alone, but many other teams.
So what I did is that
I went across Google
and talked to various teams
that were doing related work.
And there was, again,
a lot of demand
for this type of thinking,
this really sophisticated, more
advanced visualization models.
And you can think about
this not as your typical bar
chart or your pie
chart, but something
like a natural visualization,
something like a really
sophisticated timeline.
These are not the
things that are
available at the simplest
data visualization
toolkits available out there.
So the demand was definitely
there. however, there was not
a lot of teams able to
build it as we wanted,
as we needed for GCP.
So, I was able to convince
our leadership that this
was a huge sort of opportunity.
So I was able to build
that team from scratch.
And I think now we are around
14 people, and a mix of UX
designers, researchers,
UX engineers, essentially
prototypers, and
software engineers
actually building
some of the components
that we are creating.
JON FOUST: Awesome.
So you said something
very interesting.
You had to convince
the leadership
that this was very important.
So, can you tell our listeners
why data visualization
is so important?
MANUEL LIMA: I like
to think about this--
one way is called the
understanding spectrum.
This is how data converts
into information,
information converts
into knowledge,
and knowledge
converts into wisdom.
This is the understanding
spectrum, normally.
Now, data visualization
really comes in
in building a bridge between
information and knowledge,
which is also the hardest part.
Information surrounds
us every single day,
and our ability to actually
generate data and information
has, by far, outpaced our
ability to actually make
sense of that data.
And that's where data
visualization can come in.
It's almost a lens
for understanding.
It allows us to understand
in a graphical way a lot
of the hidden patterns in
the data and in information
that you wouldn't see otherwise.
So that's the metaphor of, like,
making the invisible visible
is so powerful.
GABI FERRARA: So, if
you can tell us what
your team been up to lately.
MANUEL LIMA: Yeah,
that's a great question.
So we've been pretty busy.
Our team is kind of
operating in various fronts.
We, of course, act as
consultants internally.
We help a lot of teams again,
mostly in cloud and GCP,
but even in other areas.
Teams that are dealing with
complex issues pertaining
to data visualization-- maybe
they are building another chart
or they are building this
sophisticated dashboard.
Some of these challenges
are external-facing that are
customers outside--
let's say Google
Analytics, for example,
but other are internal.
We have a lot of
internal dashboards,
a lot of internal
tools that deal
with really sophisticated
ways of visualizing data
and information.
And we come in as consultants.
We support them.
We help them achieve a
better product overall.
And also, of course, we
provide a lot of UX expertise.
So we help with usability,
with accessibility,
and things of that nature.
We are also very passionate
about dataviz and teaching
dataviz, so we organize things
like an internal speaker
series, where people come
in and talk about the work.
We teach data visualization in
this internal almost university
that we have at Google.
We teach other Googlers
on data visualization.
But the core of
what we do is really
building cloud charts, which
is a set of data visualization
components so that
other teams can actually
reuse them in an easy way.
That's the core of our business.
That's where most of us
are really working hard on.
And a secondary pillar
that we are trying to build
is related to design
ops, design operations.
And we are building
some tools and apps
data visualization related
to our part of teams,
be more effective, collaborate
better, and just raise
the quality of their output.
GABI FERRARA: You said--
sorry--
MANUEL LIMA: Yes.
GABI FERRARA: --just
to go back, you
said, like, teach
a lot of people
about data visualization?
MANUEL LIMA: Correct.
GABI FERRARA: How
much math do you need?
MANUEL LIMA: [LAUGHS]
GABI FERRARA: Like,
math-- like, I
don't do math for a long time.
MANUEL LIMA: Yeah.
That's a common
misunderstanding,
I have to say.
Like, it was kind
of like that, maybe,
I would say, 10 to 15 years ago.
If you wanted to do any
type of substantial work
in data visualization, you
would have to be good at math
and also have a good
understanding of a programming
language.
These days, you've had--
there was this democratization
of visualization tools,
so it's pretty easy
for many other people
without that expertise,
without that knowledge,
to do some really substantial
work in this domain.
And I think that that's been
really productive because that
has allowed the field to
grow immensely and include
many different people from
many different disciplines.
GABI FERRARA: Awesome.
So, you've mentioned that you
worked on a bunch of tooling,
and you work with
a bunch of teams,
and you do a lot of courses.
So I'm curious,
since the team was
founded by the four of you, what
has really come out of the data
visualization team that you
can puff your chest out about?
[LAUGHTER]
MANUEL LIMA: That's good.
I mean, staffing the
team was really fun.
I'm, of course, a UX manager,
so I love growing teams,
you know, finding
the right culture,
growing them in a
balanced way, making sure
that we have the right
cross-discipline ratios,
and making sure we are building
the right talent in part
of that group of people.
So I love that.
That is one of the things that
I feel most proud of, just
building our team from scratch.
With the right
capability, everyone
being so passionate for this
domain just definitely helps.
And I feel this is also
something that I carried around
with my career.
I believe that
passion is a magnet.
It contaminates others and it
allows you to do a lot more.
And I feel like we
have done so much
with a small group
of people because we
have that drive, because we
have that huge passion for data
visualization.
But one of the
things that I feel,
again, is staffing the
team, but also reaching out.
A lot of times, we do amazing
work internally at Google,
but we don't actually
go outside and actually
talk to other people and teach
them as well what we're doing.
So, a few months back, we
partnered with the Material
Team and we actually launched
externally for everyone to use.
So everyone that's
listening to us
can actually go and see a set
of data visualization guidelines
that we did in partnership
with Material, detailing things
like the graphical language
that you should use,
what type of charts you
need for a given situation--
a lot of really
interesting principles.
And this has been
extremely successful.
I think right now that
Material section has
been seen by around 100,000
unique users and the principles
that we published
on Medium has been
seen by roughly 60,000 people.
There's definitely a lot of
appetite, a lot of interest,
for this type of
material, and I'm
really proud for us to be
reaching out to our users
outside of Google.
JON FOUST: Awesome.
So I'm going to circle
back to about the tooling
that you've mentioned
and a lot of the teams
that you work with.
For your team, you're all
very passionate about data
visualization.
But curious, does everybody
need to be an expert on data
or just be passionate about
it to actually get into this?
MANUEL LIMA: That's
a good point.
I think passion helps,
but we have had people
joining the team that didn't
have a solid background
or expertise in this space.
They were, like, just
tremendous researchers
or tremendous designers and they
just had that appetite for it.
So, I think you can definitely
excel, but again, in my view,
passion goes a long way.
It just allows you to that
extra 10% of dedication.
GABI FERRARA: So once
you build this, basically
a set of guidelines
for data visualization
that people will use
across different teams.
How hard was it to build
something like that, because
like the fact that you said
you're a horizontal team,
there is a kind of uniformity
to everything that you're doing,
and so, it's more common
across the product.
And how do you work to
maintain that kind of identity?
MANUEL LIMA: I think that's
one of the challenges.
And I'm sure the
audience is probably
familiar with the Material team.
The Material team is
this internal group
that really strives
to build consistency
in terms of the UI and UX across
our various products, Google
products, which is a huge
challenge on its own right.
So we, in some ways, are
a smaller Material team
but just focused on
data visualization.
So, we have the same challenge,
albeit a much smaller team.
But you're right.
I think it comes in two ways.
One is the guidelines,
and then the other one
is providing the specific
components that others can use.
And they kind of
go hand in hand.
On the guidelines, the work
that we did started earlier on,
I would say maybe 18 months ago
or so-- or even two years ago.
The first time is when a
group of us across Google
got together--
I think we did a couple
of sprints on this--
and this was a
really wide effort.
This was, I think, 12 different
product areas across Google,
from Google Analytics, Search,
Google Cloud, all these PAs,
that we call internally.
So, all these designers from all
these groups getting together
and thinking about what would
the right set of guidelines
that we could provide
in a unified way,
so that everyone
else on the team
could build the
right type of chart?
At the time, we were
not even thinking
about providing a
specific component
that you could actually use.
We were just a
set of guidelines.
And that became our internal
Google dataviz spec.
This is again
available internally
and the one that we ended up
publishing by the Material team
externally is just
a subset of that.
So internally,
it's a bit heavier.
We cover almost everything from
motion design to interaction.
We cover aspects of this on
the external one as well,
but the internal is, by
far, more comprehensive.
That was a really fun project.
That was a really fun sort of
initiative to be part of that,
and that has been immensely
helpful for, again,
many different designers,
engineers, and researchers
across the entire company.
So that was on the
guidelines aspect of it.
And then, part of that
we are doing right now
is releasing
specific components.
We are building a
library, a toolkit,
So that other engineers across
multiple different areas
as well.
And of course, most
importantly, Cloud and GCP
can leverage those components.
And consistency, to
your point, Gabrielle,
is critical because that's
one of the reasons why
we are doing this,
why we are building
this library in the first place
is that users don't get to see
a different bar
chart, a different pie
chart in every single product
that they navigate through
within GCP.
That wouldn't make sense.
Consistency builds familiarity
and it's pretty important
that people and users recognize
the same type of experience,
the same type of
charting mechanism,
across the different
products that they use
and navigate to
achieve a given task.
GABI FERRARA: So you brought
up this component library,
and I'm curious.
Of course, it's used widely
across Google internally,
but what would you say is the
biggest advantage of actually
building this out.
Internally of course, things
that happen internally
have extreme external
benefits for our users,
so I'm just curious.
What would you say is the
biggest advantage for us
internally?
MANUEL LIMA: One is
definitely building
some of the internal expertise
on this domain, which is, again
still fairly new to people.
They understand,
maybe, the benefit,
but they don't
understand how critical
it can be for even product,
even an internal product.
So, I think it's kind
of raising awareness,
and education across the
company is a really good effort.
The benefits of building a
library, per se, is multifold.
You can increase
velocity because you
don't have to reinvent
the wheel every time.
You can just pick up
the component and kind
of plug and play.
You can also minimize
a lot of the UI,
sort of, complexity
because you end up
creating auxiliary
type of UI components
that are not
productive at times.
I think you can really
increase quality--
optimize UI quality,
consistency, and effectiveness.
We talk about consistency.
It helps build familiarity.
It helps that you find
the same type of chart
every time you navigate
to a different product.
And I think it can be a
huge driver for innovation.
Impressing our customers and
be, really, a differentiator
for GCP, as well.
GABI FERRARA: You said that
you have a set of guidelines
and that you build
first internally.
So we're kind of
like the Formula 1--
cutting edge
internally, and then you
put it outside if it is OK, and
safe, and that kind of stuff.
So how is the process to
publishing these guidelines
for the outside world?
MANUEL LIMA: It was
easier in the sense
that we had a body of
content already to rely on.
We didn't invent
everything from scratch,
even though we ended up creating
a bunch of new content just
for that external
publishing alone.
But the process was really
a strong partnership
with the Material team.
We have been very close
since the beginning,
since the inception
of our group,
working very closely with
them reviewing content
several times.
And they are very, of course,
familiar with the process.
And again, we actually published
under the material.io website
so they are very familiar with
the whole process of iterating
on content,
publishing, and so on.
So that was usually helpful.
And then also, we
published under the Google
Design on Medium,
and that's also
co-owned by the Material
team, so that partnership
was fundamental, I would say.
And in case you
might be wondering
about what those
guidelines can be,
we kind of started
off with principles.
Principles are things that
can be fundamental for users
to understand-- how
do they actually get
started with data
visualization, right?
Principles might be used
for you to either evaluate
a specific data visualization
work, a chart that you're
working on, or even before
you even start doing anything,
just to start inspiring and
scaffoling the whole project.
So one of the principles
we have, for example,
is "be honest."
Data accuracy and
integrity come first.
Don't destroy or confuse
information for embellishment
or partiality.
As with any form of
communication, charts--
data visualization-- can
be used for good or bad.
So being honest, being accurate
is really critical for us
what we do as Google.
Another principle,
just as an example,
is "lend a helping hand."
A lot of the charts that we do,
a lot of the components we do,
can be fairly complex
to understand.
You know, it requires a
substantial learning curve.
So, finding ways of
lending a helping hand,
providing the context and help--
users navigating the
data is really important.
Building the right
visual, for instance--
that can comfort
users that this is
something that's doable, that
they can learn in fast way.
GABI FERRARA: These principles--
they sound very, very similar
to a lot of our core
values at Google.
So I'm just curious, how
did these come about?
MANUEL LIMA: So, the
principles were really
an interesting project.
A lot of that work was
from that original team
of designers across Google,
those 12 different product
areas that we got
together in a few sprints.
That was the genesis of it.
We then iterated a few times.
We also talked to a lot
of different areas, even
the hardware team at Google.
They have their own
set of principles.
We have our own
brand principles.
There's multiple
instances within Google
that have their own sort
of specific principles,
but there are a few ones that
are really common and shared
across the company.
So we talked to a
bunch of those people.
We also use research.
Research has been
really critical for us.
Very recently, we just
published internally a report
on data visualization needs
of 33 different product teams
within GCP, by far the
most comprehensive research
study we ever conducted.
And through a lot
of that research,
we kind of add a really
solid understanding
of what users actually wanted,
what our customers needed
pertaining to data
visualization, what
was really important to them.
And all those things put
together, we just mix it up,
and we generate a final list of
six guiding principles that you
can find on our Medium post.
And I believe we can
actually serve as a link
to that article on the
GCP podcasts on the show.
GABI FERRARA: On the
show notes, yeah.
So, you've written
this article and it's
been amplified outside.
Apparently this is
something new to me--
"Fast Company" actually wrote
an article about the work.
So I'm curious, how
has this been received?
MANUEL LIMA: Yeah.
I mean, my understanding it
has been pretty well received.
Again, like, we have had
close to 100,000 unique views
on the Material section that
you can find on material.io,
under communication,
and then a whole section
on data visualization.
And then, I've been following
on social media, it's been,
you know, especially
after "Fast Company"
and a few other media
outlets talked about it,
I think it's been
pretty well received.
People are really
interested in what
Google has to say pertaining
to data visualization.
And there was also the Medium
post which got a lot of buzz
on the principles.
And I think that people
tend to gravitate
towards the principles because
they are not highly specific.
They are just more
generative than prescriptive,
and I think that resonates
with people a lot more.
And we are thinking about doing
enhancements also, by the way,
to those guidelines on
the material.io site.
Right now, there's a lot of
content on the types of charts
that you might pick.
Sometimes you have
a given data set,
but you don't really know what
chart you should be using,
so we provide a lot
of guidance on that.
We also provide guidance
on the graphic language
that you need to build.
So, how to use color, how to
use typography, how to use
shape to convey a
given sort of concept.
So we provide a lot of guidance.
And I think people have found
that to be extremely useful.
That level of specificity
that we also provide--
not just the principles,
high-level principles,
but also like the
do's and dont's--
what to do and what not to do--
on specific areas
of building a chart
and building a
data visualization.
GABI FERRARA: Based on
those guidelines you posted,
those principles
that you mentioned,
is there any outside company
or anyone else outside Google
that you see successfully
implementing this, or in a way
that you didn't
thought, even, that was
possible to be able to do it?
MANUEL LIMA:
Unfortunately, I haven't--
I haven't actually
been contacted or seen
anything of that nature.
It's more like the, kind of,
people reaching out to me
and saying, hey,
this was very useful.
We are using it in a given way.
But I don't think I've actually
seen tangible output influenced
by our guidelines.
But maybe it's just
a matter of time.
[LAUGHTER]
JON FOUST: We
would like to think
Manuel Lima for joining us.
It's been a pleasure.
With him, right now,
currently recording,
you can see how very passionate
he is about data visualization.
So it's great to see
how you've really
tried to impact
internally with Google,
and also sharing those
guidelines and principles
with our external audiences.
So that's perfect.
So, we'll be sure to share
all of these blog posts,
as well as the principles,
in the show notes
so that all of our listeners
will be able to follow along.
And hopefully, we'll see some
adoption of the principles
and guidelines along
with a general interest
in general data visualization
and how we go about it.
GABI FERRARA: That was a
really nice conversation, yeah.
MANUEL LIMA: Thank you so much.
GABI FERRARA: Obrigado.
MANUEL LIMA: Obrigado.
[LAUGHTER]
GABI FERRARA: So, back to the
question of the week, Jon--
what are the most common
products used in cloud gaming?
JON FOUST: I'll probably
go over a couple,
but one product that I've seen a
big shift to was Cloud Spanner.
Customers have been using
Cloud Spanner to store, like,
player authentication data and
inventories, or pretty much
any long-term state storage.
So, the great
thing about it it's
relatively quick, scalable,
and highly available,
so there's been definitely been
a big shift to Cloud Spanner.
Another product that's been
used quite often is Redis,
one of the open source projects
that we work on, Open Match,
comes default with
Redis, and it's
used for state storage
or caching player
data, which allows the
framework to actually access
that data relatively
quickly and creates
very competitive
matches very quickly.
So, that's also another
part of the [INAUDIBLE]
seeing a big shift towards.
And it's widely
known that VMs have
been used as a product
for game servers,
but there's been a big
shift to Kubernetes.
Big shout-out to Mark
in the Agones project.
I plug him every week I can.
[LAUGHS]
But there's been a big
shift to using Kubernetes
because it's highly scalable
and highly available.
And the great thing about
it is that it auto-scales.
And I think that
whenever one of your pods
goes down and always
spins right back up,
the product, in itself,
just speaks to the power
that it would have in gaming.
And the last product
that I've been
using personally quite a
bit for my personal project
is Pub / Sub.
I've been using it a lot
for messaging, as well
as sending data relatively
quickly between two clients.
So Pub / Sub is great
because, if done right,
you should have real-time
messaging between two clients.
So if you're interested,
feel free to check out
all of the links for all of
these products in our show
notes
GABI FERRARA: OK.
Just reminding people that
we do have a Cloud Memory
Storage, which is
Redis compatible,
so you can be using that, too.
JON FOUST: And the great
thing about Open Match
is that Redis just
comes default,
but pretty much any
component can be swapped out.
So if you want to
use Memorystore,
if you want to use Firestore,
pretty much anything
that you want to use for storing
or caching your play data
you can easily just swap out.
And that also goes for pretty
much any other component
of the project as well.
So, feel free to
check out the notes
and if I can grab a couple
of presentations on it,
I'll add it along as well.
What are you going to be doing?
What are going to be up to?
GABI FERRARA: I'm going
to be doing actually,
not a database talk
but a serverless
talk at Full Stack Europe in
Antwerp, Belgium next week.
I think I'm going to be
speaking on the 24th or 25th.
The link will be
in the show notes.
And I'm excited
about that because I
know a bit of Cloud Run.
I know a bit of App
Engine and functions,
but it's fun to be
sharing with people
what those products can do,
even with databases connected
to them.
JON FOUST: It's pretty good
that you're pretty versatile.
[LAUGHTER]
GABI FERRARA: We
try to be, right?
JON FOUST: Right.
Yeah, and for me, I will
be at Q-Comm in November,
and then I'm going to be doing
quite a bit of personal travel.
I'll be in Kirkland to meet
with some engineering teams
and then I'll be
hanging out in New York,
possibly going to some distant
location just for vacation.
I'm going to probably roll a
large-sided dice to determine
where I'm going to land.
Looking forward to just
taking a spontaneous vacation.
GABI FERRARA: You
should go to Brazil.
[LAUGHS]
JON FOUST: No, I can't
go to Brazil without you.
Remember, you're
going to host me.
GABI FERRARA: Oh, yeah.
But I'm going there in
December, so you can come.
JON FOUST: And hopefully
our timelines align.
GABI FERRARA: OK.
OK, everybody.
Thank you so much for
listening to the podcast today
and have a good week.
JON FOUST: Thanks for listening.
[MUSIC PLAYING]